so I did what all of us would do I dried
the underwear off as best as I could
shut up shut up shut up this is not easy
for me
[Music]
- common you guys are gonna absolutely
love he's one of my favorites please
give it up for mr. Rory Scovel there's
no reason why any kid should ever assume
ever in their life that if they were to
fart hard enough they could
themselves think about that like as a
kid why would you ever assume that's an
outcome why would you ever assume that's
even a possibility the only way you
would know that for sure is if an adult
told you and that's clearly the
creepiest adult in the world hey bud
come here for a second that's right tell
your parents we have a relationship
right along have a good one creepy
neighbor hey another kid isn't gonna
tell you that if another kid told you
then you know it happened to them they
don't want to out themselves the only
way to find out that that's a scenario
scenario is the hard way and now we all
know what this story's about the music
kicks in I was 11 I didn't know who I
was then but I found out I was 11 years
old I was I was if I can open up to you
guys I was headed to a back-to-school
end of the summer pool party at a
friend's house and this is going into
seventh grade this is when it starts to
matter you know what I mean
before seventh grade you didn't give a
you just did whatever you did but
as soon as like you were going we were
you start caring what people think it's
really the moment in time
where everything becomes horrific for
the rest of your life because you start
to care so much about what people people
think I'm on my way to this pool party
my stepmothers driving we got a stop at
gymnastics to pick up my sister she gets
out of the car runs inside to grab her
I'm just sitting in the car I have to
fart you know what I mean
little did I know I had to little
did I know I had to I thought I
only had to fart I thought you know what
I got a fart move some stuff around in
here we all think that you have to
you go halfway fart a little bit make a
little room move the furniture around
little Fung Shui of the guts do a little
Fung Shui of the gut if we can I farted
and my world changed I was no longer
just an innocent child the world became
a real place a 1 second ago I was just a
normal kid now I'm someone who
understands that people die every day
every day people die that's the world we
truly live in and I now know that when
you're 11 and you fart in your
car and yourself you're like huh
what you first you have to just grasp
the concept that that's the thing you
didn't know that yeah ok noted never do
this again
never never have this kind of confidence
you got to figure out how to fix the
situation all right I got to go inside I
got to sort this out at about 30 yards
between the car and the front door into
the gymnastics place and that's what
we'll call it the gymnastics place those
are the words I've chosen for this story
you have 30 yards to figure out how to
walk as though it looks like you didn't
just yourself when you first got
out of the car you're waddling a little
bit because it gives you kind of an idea
of what you're working with back there
how much did I you know what I mean
you don't know waddle a little bit try
to see where are the boundaries
you can't waddle for too long because if
someone sees you waddling their first
guess is that you've yourself no
one's like oh that kid has a problem
like no he probably himself I bet
he found out the hard way that life is
real you have 30 cards to go from like
ah to like some sort of upright big left
arm swing hi I'm a member of the country
club how are you
I'm 11 I pay my monthly dues yeah 30
yards to figure out how to walk as as
soon as you get through those doors now
there's people watching and you got to
get to the bathroom I get in there
there's not a men's room and a women's
room there's just one bathroom that
everybody has to use like individually I
know right like even then gymnastics
didn't have the funding it's a up
situation I get in there and I see the
bathroom bolt past everybody go in close
the door home free here we are in the
bathroom where we can really fix this
situation
what do I do first I get the underwear
off folks I'm not an animal I try to
clean them as best as I can in the sink
picture what you want I don't care
whatever you picture that is truly what
happened I tried to clear him in the
sink okay we all have the same thought
let's go I thought maybe I can just take
these off clean them throw them in the
trash can there's not like a regular
trash can in the bathroom that has like
a trash bag in it there was one tiny
little pail trash can with zero other
trash items in it so that's out I'm not
gonna throw my shitty underwear in the
trash walk out the next person comes in
hey did you leave your shitty underwear
in the trash I thought I could flush my
underwear okay
little did I know how relatable this
story truly was till that groan right no
you can't bro everyone's got a cigarette
for some rib no you can't you can't
flush that you can't flush that not not
imagine stopping up the toilet
you walk out someone's like I'm sorry
did you try to flush your clothes
because you're dumb why did you wipe
yourself with your clothes and then
flush them so I did what all of us would
do I dried the underwear off as best as
I could shut up
oh shut up this is not easy for me this
is a part of my 12-step program okay go
to a strip club and tell the story it's
weird that that's the first step but it
is I go to very all t ay ay ay ay ay I
Drive them off as best as I can I have a
bunch of paper towels I'm wringing them
out come on then I shove them into my
pocket yeah I shove him in my pocket
what am I gonna do I'm trying to
figure it out I'm 11 honestly for 11 I'm
like pretty smart kid
hello Harvard Yale others others I don't
know uh I shove them into my pocket I
get back in the car we're on our way to
the pool party no one in the car knows
my stepmom doesn't know my sister
doesn't know I'm sitting there just like
I was going through like customs with a
suitcase of blow oh god I'm redneck
Johnny Depp I get to the party my
stepmothers just dropping me off so
she's just pulling up I'm jumping out I
get out of the car I can hear everybody
in the backyard at the pool I go up to
the front door I knock no one answers
it's unlocked I go in thinking now I'm
gonna have to interact with people be
ready go inside there's no one in the
house there's a stairwell right in front
of me I go right up it in my head I'm
like there's a bathroom at the top of
the stairs I'll go in that bathroom
people will be like Oh Rory got here and
he had to go to the bathroom little do
they know I already had
still what is the solution that's what
I'm going through I can't leave the
underwear in the trash can here this is
even worse than the gymnastics place I'm
definitely not flushing them here I know
that outside of this bathroom to my
right is my friend Michael's bedroom to
my left is his younger brother's bedroom
I take the underwear out of my pocket I
open the door and I just watch
them into the corner of his younger
brother's room I see them I see it hit
the corner and fall behind the bed I
walk away I walk away it's not me
anymore that's no longer a part of me
that's not my issue I don't know what
you're talking about officer why are you
at this party why did they hire the
police that's a better question I walk
away what's funny about this story in my
mind is that I was on a friend's podcast
and they were telling stories about
themselves and it was only then
that it occurred to me that I even had
this story that's how powerful the human
mind is I erased what everything I just
told you happened exactly the way I just
told you and I erased that from my
memory so that I could continue as a
person because if I already got hung up
on that there's no way I would be public
speaking at a strip club I had to move
on and I remembered oh my god that did
happen to me and also I now remember my
stepmother used to write my name in some
some of my underwear how up is
that
not even all of them or none of them
some of them how lazy can you be if I
had 10 pairs of underwear she probably
wrote it in like four pairs of underwear
to this day I have no idea if my name
was written
in that pair of underwear I threw it I
walked away I thought that's gone is it
as a stand-up comedian I've been
fortunate enough to get to do some
things on television not a lot I think a
good amount of things if you're trying
to do things on television I've been
fortunate enough to get to do some and
I'm happy about it
and I've always been been grateful for
that but now knowing about this past
that I deleted from my memory I wonder
is there any chance my name wasn't that
underwear and anyone in that family has
ever seen me do anything the current
thing I'm doing right now is going to be
on television
I just is there a part of them that has
ever seen something like well go back go
back go my go go go that gonna go down
go down go down go down one channel well
then go up two channels go up to channel
his name that hard thank you there no
stop go back there him that guy that
right there
that's the guy who ruined our family you
see that Michael see him you remember
him
look at him that guy right there that
guy's the reason your brother killed
himself oh you wanted a happy ending I'm
on television telling the story